we recorded you are listening to the
dollop UK in England I flipped it you
are listening to the dollop England and
the UK on the all things comedy Network
this is a ten episode season special
season of the dollop and we're focusing
on England and the United Kingdom
because that bothers people that we say
those two things you say those two
things yeah it's fun so give it the
intro you're not doing a proper intro
what do you mean be like hey you're
listening to the dollop England UK every
week I Dave Anthony hey you're listening
to the dollop stop laughing okay this is
a an English history podcast and we do a
little bit UK also each week I read a
story from UK history to my friend
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what
this UK topic will be about and I'm Dave
Anthony and no you don't because you
never know that's the exciting thing
about this podcast it's thrill is that
you don't know what's happening there's
no net there's no net there's no net
you're just a guy flying through the air
you're not ran don't read anything
called it quote is jam catch is it for
fun and this is not gonna come
particularly podcast yeah now hit him
with the puppy you both lose a sip
argument
you may now read
thank you David this Saturday at 10:00
p.m. we'll be at the main room at
flappers comedy club in Burbank
California with ton of great people
potentially you we're finding out you
can and and that'll be at 10:00 p.m. and
then on October 2nd I'll be doing the
show the Venice underground which is at
a place called the underground in Venice
at 10 p.m. as well or sorry a p.m. and
will be in Madison Wisconsin on October
18th and Milwaukee on October 20th then
we are heading to a rope in November
starting in Stockholm on the 10th then
we go to Oslo Amsterdam Glasgow
Manchester London Birmingham Cardiff
Dublin then we have now added a second
show in London on the 22nd I guess we
should mention I guess for that one is
Boris Johnson is Boris Johnson and it
will be a completely different topic
someone else to say every show is a
different topic we never repeat a topic
we can't because that's doesn't work for
the podcast we really should just start
if people are if the expectation is this
low we should just do be like I would do
it a classic that's right we should just
go toward the room and we're going to
the rope and then we're gonna be in
Copenhagen I think Copenhagen and
Glasgow were sold out yeah I believe
that those are sold out and then it one
of the one the first one the first live
show so but please join us on our tour
of the Europe's yep
anything else before we get into crazy
oh we should mention the pike we have a
new theme song we do yeah what sorry
yeah we do in a dollop again for the UK
doing a dollop again not America do it
without up again it's different that do
it I thought up again for the Queen okay
all right yeah get the riff behind I got
up UK all right
yeah yeah okay I mean I September 1931
we don't have an exact date Arthur
Thompson was born in a spring burn the
spring burn district of Glasgow okay so
this is a Scottish right understood
Scotland
his parents were too devoutly
working-class parents of Protestants
okay as a young boy Arthur was a
troublemaker and when awful often get
into fistfights with classmates sure by
the time he was 12 he started carrying
razors around he uses way well that's
mighty early but again got to take I
think the equation is time how Scottish
and age and I think actually if you do
the Venn diagram where you'll see that
it's a pinhole but this is where they
dress yes it doesn't work with the Papa
razors for school gotcha
I've got Fame the copy of the kids
during his teenage years world war two
was on and glass again the area
specifically that he lived in was
industrialized so of constantly being
bombed by the Germans sure it was during
this time that Arthur began his criminal
career I think some would argue he
started it at twelve so he initially
robbed local stores and then he moved on
to be a debt collector for loan sharks
interesting he's moving up yeah next he
extorted bars or stores protection money
right yeah that old gag he's making good
money but he got caught and sentenced to
jail for 18 months okay
he hated prison so much that he vowed to
avoid arrest at all costs this will be
the last time that and all the deities
know what's going back no again no way
so once released Arthur made connections
in London and began working for gangs
there sure and continuing his vow to
never go back to jail that's right well
he could have gotten a job sure or just
no I'm not you say that to your mother
she's just like oh well that's cute I'm
glad you've to say did you can attend
open
walking get caught that's new what I've
seen I'm not getting a bloody regular
job I'm done with everything
I'm joined in gangs but won't cool down
his lent his London rep grew and grew
and the Kray twins up hello who were the
most powerful British gangsters of all
time
wanted Arthur out of their city and
let's also the inventors of curbing I
believe the architects of the curb stomp
I mean it's a beautiful the first people
to say but the could is it true I
thought maybe I'm wrong but I know they
were doing it a popular story amongst
criminals was that Arthur heard the
Crais wanted him gone so he went to
their London nightclub and casually
asked to see them this is a very
Scottish move he then pulled a sawed-off
shotgun from his coat and pointed it at
the crazed heads and said quote my name
is Arthur Thompson of Glasgow you'll no
forget me it's great that right after
that he became friends with them an
enforcer for the craze interesting so
that is that tells you what you're
dealing with
well they're pretty I mean it's twofold
right it's a you get a baddie uh-huh and
you eliminate an enemy you do and it's
like an it's like an interview or an
audition sure the way that's a good gang
but it's not like a straight-up audition
it's like whether it's like but how
Benicio del Toro audition well they
don't hold auditions auditions are more
sporadic and random yeah but still but
still it's like one of those guys are
like you know just shows up at a bar in
front of a director he's like I can do
this and the guy's like all right yeah
it's like that one-in-a-million
so in 1966
Arthur was almost killed when a bomb
exploded at his mg sports car his
mother-in-law was in the passenger seat
and she was killed
Arthur suspected two men from the rival
Welsh gang and sometime after he saw
them in a van and forced it off the road
and into a lamppost and both men were
killed Jesus Arthur was charged with
murder but no witnesses would come
forward and he was released well The Vow
continues believe no one would come The
Vow continues three years later his wife
Rita forced her way into the Welsh home
and stabbed
one of the Bombers wives in the chest
she went to jail for three years so
they're good yeah our couple you have
things you like stabbing yeah that's
like how you bond yeah no yeah it's over
like your third date where you just like
and they what what's your feeling I'm
like stabbing and things like that I
love it well it's tremendous no I'm uh
I'm Pro stabbing myself what yeah it's
hard to find a last he's got the scene
no I love it
you got really nice tits Arthur became
one of the most feared man in the
country if someone didn't pay their
debts he would literally crucify them
nailing families nailing them to the
wall or the floor there's a picture oh
no not of a crucifixion just over Arthur
okay that comes up okay well he looks
pretty like normal though I don't know
how to work yeah I wouldn't even [ __ ]
with it oh you can't okay a computer
enhance yeah it looks a little like
McCartney ish he doesn't look like you
know back then
gangsters didn't look like our gangsters
now you know they dressed nice and they
looked great yeah well especially if I
make a vow to never go to jail again
that's right so so he now people the
floor or walls as I said as you do when
you're looking to get money she's he
became known as The Godfather of Glasgow
okay and was the most sought after debt
collector in the United Kingdom okay
Scotland was known for its criminals and
more major players emerged throughout
the 70s and 80s
Thomas McGraw was born on February 19th
1952 in Lennox town outside of Glasgow
he was known as Tam I'm also Scottish
and he committed petty crimes as a kid
okay
got into fights razors razors now he's
21 in and out of reform schools or
juvenile detention
he marries trout childhood sweetheart
Margaret mags McGraw known as the
jeweler sure Jesus Christ because of her
love of gold and diamonds oh right so
rare at the time to a very unique
quality for someone and she operated the
business side of Tam's criminal
activities laundering his money through
a cab company several pubs and a private
security firm she's the she's the
business right ladies savvy police
corruption was at an all-time high
police corruption has always been at all
it seems like they've gotten lower it's
yeah it's not great ATandT took
advantage and became a police informant
for the Serious Crime Squad for the
serious questions to the gup-a one they
named they named their Detroit the
shittiest one no they so it was like
their top I don't know what we'd call
art our top like investigative unit but
that's what they call the buzz go it was
the serious crime school good work it's
very serious it's not to be taken as a
joke
so smile in in exchange for being an
informant he got you know leniency from
the cops sure he was the most wanted
criminal in Scotland but he became
untouchable because of his tattletale
yeah so also Scotland at this time was
the murder capital of Europe okay cool I
mean gotta be number one it's something
yeah no it's good that's good that's
good
police felt constant pressure to make
arrests so to help Tamil to implicate
men in crimes that they didn't commit
which we've run into yeah but recently
it's the first time I've felt anti
waterboarding in a long time
tam did not hide his relationship with
the cops they went to his bar and he
could be seen serving drinks and he
earned the nickname the licensee because
he had a license to kill and police
backing him to commit crimes criminals
were suspicious but could not prove to
him as a snitch okay
early on Tama joined a small criminal
organization called the bar L team okay
they specialize in armed robberies Tam
ratted out the leader who was arrested
so he is getting he's getting everything
yeah he's getting the ability to go rob
places and then as soon as they're done
he's turning into people that he just
did it with yeah I don't know if he's
doing that but he's he's I know if he's
ratting out his gang in this case he
wanted to get rid of the leader of the
gang so he did but right I don't think
he rats out his own gang it's still
probably not a guy you want to be having
open conversation I wouldn't okay so
Thomas T C Campbell took over as the
leader of the gang okay or team
TC was the son of a famous safecracker
and leader of the gaúcho razor gang okay
so cool do you know what a gaucho is no
it is a Venezuelan cowboy oh okay I did
know that so I'm not sure why they named
it that but a gaucho razor razor gang
yeah okay yeah if it had a mustache I
would say Groucho razors yeah yeah and I
cut myself am i cutting you off
excuse me ma'am he was known for
surviving suicide missions against other
gangs the Sunday Herald described tc's
childhood quote like everyone else he
carried a knife and used it he was sorry
I'm gonna actually need to sorry what's
his childhood story like everyone else
he carried a knife and used its Scotland
like everyone else everyone has a knife
it carried a knife and used it he was
first stabbed when he was 15 he says
offering to show me oh this is when he's
being interviewed he says offering to
show me his guts where his guts spilled
out yes would you like to have a look at
where all the guts poured into me well
that got wine look at the get wine after
that he was knifed regularly I tried to
do it once the twice a week is a dreamin
and in a book he occurred reg Mackay a
former social worker he remembers
sitting in a pub when he was 17 and
being attacked three times by someone
wielding a hammer everyone who had seen
it thought they had witnessed my murder
and I couldn't believe I hardly felt it
who gets hit with a hammer so there's
something wrong with his head yeah it's
like there's people when they get tased
then it's like they don't work I'm gonna
do summaries it's like I'm actually good
oh yeah if you hit someone with a hammer
three times and there are that still
there you're like oh I'm gonna get
beaten bad and they literally just turn
like a what yeah what you see what
you're doing there what did you lay in
Glasgow criminals backed up TC stories
and said they once saw TC
single-handedly fight off five to ten
men on his own while he held his
intestines in after being gutted with a
knife so what he's just have they not
sewn them up so it's just kind of like
spilling out still Scotland I mean it's
just how it wasn't yeah no yeah of
course and actually that's just called
heaven haggis huge I said me I'm having
hoggish again pardon you just see a guy
walking through this guts oh my god say
blend a son of a bus thing Tommy got
stabbed no it's no even though it's not
even though I ever been stabbed what's
it what's go in the G look at that I am
just bloody spilling [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
good
see how me that fork give me now I'm
gonna poop myself good give me the spoon
of spaghetti myself bucking wind it up
push that it is let's go to the pub
you're I'm ready to drink so during a
bar L team heist Tam almost killed a cop
not Tam's the the guy who can get away
with well he was arrested tried and
quickly acquitted and other charges are
dropped so he did he kill a cop he
almost did so he now is like if you're a
cop here like this is not good well
there's a guy he got away with it okay
TC despised snitches and was suspicious
of Tim and Tam knew TC was suspicious
and wouldn't hesitate to spread the word
if he was a snitch so Tam became
determined to get rid of TC so wait one
superpower is the power of spreading
rumor and the other superpower is he's a
snitch yeah okay Tam ordered the
jailbreak of three
Tim wanted the cops to charge TC as
their mastermind of the breakout and
within days TC was arrested okay he was
the perfect person to take the fall the
problem was there was absolutely no
evidence and TC had a solid alibi so the
trial was very quick and TC was
acquitted and Tam was furious okay
the bio team bar L team kept pulling
heists while Tam's attempts to remove TC
from the group kept failing TC was very
skilled and the others really liked
working with him now one day one day Tam
was with the bar L team when he got a
call from his Serious Crime Squad
contact so you mean there was just like
the red phone lit up hold on a minute
boys the red phone and it was a warning
that cops from a different unit were on
their way to arrest him - arrest Tam
yeah okay so so real cops are coming
yeah so the rest of the bar L team take
off right except TC who stayed nearby
and watched okay and he watched four cop
cars pull up and dragged him out of his
house okay and within minutes a unit
from the serious crime crime squad
arrived and surrounded Tam one tried to
remove Tam from the other cop car but
the other cops refused I mean what what
Looney song is playing during this
silent film then one of the cops from
the Serious Crime Squad and one of the
other cops started fighting throwing
punch at each others in the street while
Tam stood there watching okay so how
long until the Keystone's show up so two
cops are beating the [ __ ] out of each
other while Tim's like yeah hope the
super squad wins the serious crime squad
cop won the fight nice and put Tam into
his car right now you're not under
arrest
get in the car still so the next day Tam
was escorted home with no charges
against him okay TC suspicions were
confirmed Tam was a police informant and
Tam knew he absolutely had to get rid of
TC once and for all this is like
Goodfellas must it really is
in post-war and plus post-war Glasgow
housing schemes promised idyllic
affordable suburban housing to replace
old tenement buildings so they're these
cheap and they're for low income and
they're built in in convenient locations
outside of cities they're built in it's
all mostly tract housing I would
describe it okay but they're built in
shitty places that you can't really get
to anything okay
the poorly planned they had no
facilities or rooms for shops to be
built and it took a long bus ride to go
to stores but most buses didn't go
through the well that's a problem house
Express about so the free market moved
in uh-huh in the form of ice-cream fans
okay Wow so you've just got an area of
the country that's just living on ice
creams no oh so an ice-cream van would
sell it would claim a corner or an area
and sell ice cream as well as groceries
and household items okay why are there
more of those should just be driving
around everywhere like no hold on I
gotta go here's the milk I throw some
pizzas back there Teddy oh we got hooks
and I got a stepladder ah take one of
those hooks so I'm gonna keep waiting
for pizza truck so so that's a good way
to make money and corners became very
valuable right corners specifically yeah
like your corner where you park your
icecream shot sure yeah and then the
gangs took notice of this oh good I'm
sure so during the 70's and 80's
manufacturing declined obviously and
poverty rates increased then drug became
widespread particularly in the housing
schemes so this is a huge market for the
Glasgow criminals gangs made deals with
ice cream truck owners to sell their
right stolen goods cigarettes firearms
and heroin Wow the for right for me for
luring goods right well it had a good
run of being a good idea so they became
big sellers and money's rolling in more
and more criminals got ice cream trucks
sort of adorable Thanks
it's like when you put a leather jacket
on a puppy yeah so one was a
well-established hit man was one of the
first ice cream truck owners he had
several ice cream fans and he made 500
pounds a week and earned the nickname
the Ice Man
how great is it when people come up
wanting ice cream to one of the front
ones hey you may want to skip this we're
not big proponents of ice cream right
now I'm looking yeah I know the outside
says ice cream for sale yeah that's not
exactly what we've got authors have you
got well look what the ice cream truck
you know if that's why I don't wear
basically it's this ice cream on the
side heroin guns
yes okay I'll take two you just wanted
ice cream
well no well I'm not gonna bloody ah for
the boy oh it's for you boy all right
hey hey Dane child like I don't
yes get in there shooting me eyeballs
out Christ he zodiacs is brewing these
beans already it's after my own night in
the eighties Tam who's an associate of
ice man joined in on the action
sorry I I skipped over how great ice man
a moment it's fine so tan gets in on the
action and TC becomes a big player in
the ice cream business locals began
calling him the Emperor of carn't I'm
the Emperor of carnitine yeah which i
think is a city okay area okay they
would all hire drivers they called that
they called TC that yeah okay so they'd
all hire drivers to drive ice cream
trucks if a driver sold goods and
another gangs territory leaders orders
what we're known as frighteners to send
a message okey-dokey ghosts no that's a
movie oh these are worse these are bad
men well yeah the frighteners would roll
up in an ice cream truck blaring ice
cream what the [ __ ]
is happening like this wait come on
what well it's just like it's like
imagine if every gang member had to wear
like a Winnie the Pooh outfit I would
imagine that know wanting now of course
we all want that but it's just like the
threat is really weird it's not creepy
nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee you're
right meet me new new new new new boom
boom
what would you like a woolly paint a
name you knew me you step eight Sade
let's do this [ __ ] I can't believe a
Scorsese never did this so they're blair
and the ice cream truck music and then
they would attack they would slash tires
there be drive-by shootings they loot
vans they'd steal vans they beat up
drivers to scare them into leaving and
Tam and TC were the most violent of all
these guys I don't think it I think if
there needs to be an ice cream Bureau
who needs to be like no not what we
wanted so people living in the housing
schemes began to associate the song ice
cream song with impending danger there
is a generation of Facebook coming yeah
we hear our ice cream trucks like go and
say cuenca just to be safe just to be
safe wow people became fed up and then
this serious crimes Gras squad was
called in but they're in the pocket of
town yeah who has an ice cream truck
yeah so have a driver files a complaint
with the Serious Crime Squad the unit
would come to their house and pretty
much end their ice cream career okay
right some people started killing and
calling them the serious chimes squad
because they didn't do anything
one day two of Tam's police contacts who
were known by what the locals called
Laurel and Hardy because they are to say
okay okay great
they told Tam and the Bart L team that
they had to lay low for a while
if your nickname is Laurel & Hardy as
cops and it's like Scottish people like
they you just no matter how much
authority you have you have lost the fun
bit like maybe they've beaten you what'd
you say water ID splendid job man come
on Fat Boys okay come on now listen
we're just asking your voice to keep it
Dean that's all I'm asking you for a
cool [ __ ] corner keeper so it turns
out the loyalist movement in Northern
Ireland believe the Bartel team was
sending money to the RRA
okay so Tam halted bar-tailed jobs
immediately that's the one thing he's
like oh no okay yeah right don't want to
get and the troubles were good my
parents are here
the parents are here guys the parents
are here but he still needed money
coming in sure so he began rapidly
expanding his ice cream operation Tam
had his eye on a Gotham lock which was a
very profitable neighborhood for ice
cream vans Garthim lock that sounds like
we're evil me lives yeah thank you kind
of a little bit but Grantham lock was
controlled by T C's sister Agnes okay
she was doing very well because her
goods were affordable and never inflated
for extra profit so this is a TC
stronghold in a way and Tam is looking
to get involved yeah
her big competitor in the area worked
for the Marchetti firm the marchetti's
tried to scare Agnes off okay they sent
six vans to try to drive her out but
locals kept going to Agnes his ice cream
truck okay and then the Marchetti is
told cops Agnes was selling stolen goods
right classic and when the cops
approached Agnes is ice cream van she
had the receipts for everything to
prevent is ready the marchetti's they
decided to leave one van in gotham lock
just a hassle Agnes okay cool
the driver was Andrew Doyle who was
known as fat boy okay
sure [ __ ] boy now he well I get to in a
bit but he was 18 years old very large
hard-working but exceptionally kind so
instead of harassing Agnes as he was
ordered to do he would often just pull
up next to her and chowder well you're
right on Agnes well you seem nice
all right have a good day sorry sorry
for the bother
oh she's got to be scared Tim wanted
control of Gotham lock for himself so he
ordered his men to move in on Fat Boy
it's on his team know if a boys not on
it oh that boys the Marchetti totally do
all right sorry I'm not Tam is trying to
get rid of Apple right but they both
okay yeah and then I guess he'd go up
dragging us after right so they both
have the same goal but he's like get rid
of Fat Boy yes to get rid of it so he
tried to buy him out scare him off but
Fat Boy is young he was very moral and
fiercely loyal he got surrounded by
friends he got bullied nothing he's not
given in they shot a sawed-off shotgun
through his windshield Fat Boy would not
give it nice today so Tam went for an
escalation with his frighteners on April
16th 18 sorry 1984 a large fire burned
the home of fat boy where his family
left Jesus the death count was six oh
[ __ ]
the dead were fat boy actually that one
there's pictures of fat boy after the
fire being let out and he's just walking
and then he died the next day well from
just like inhalation or something or I
didn't look like he was burned so must
have got fat boys brother James doe
brother father fat boy's father James
Doyle his brother James his brother Tony
his sister Christina her son Mark who
was 18 months ago that's an escalation
only three of the nine in the family
survived
it was the biggest recorded murder in
Scotland at the time in the media went
wild and people in the city were [ __ ]
livid yeah
the investigation revealed the house had
been covered in petrol gas for American
yes on Reds a young girl who sold petrol
to two men came forward now I didn't I
don't know what that meant like oh yeah
well I just read that and I was like
okay what is there a girl on the street
just selling petrol like what yeah well
you need anything else no sandwiches in
fact no one cop showed her a photo to a
full bar okay all good things about
crocodile no okay I don't want to buy
boy yeah no we're like you look good
look you know like a lagoon okay are you
just selling one legume at a time we'll
go to the lagoon okay oh I saw one on
the gun okay what follow me
I've got wings I can't fly
well that was weird that was a weird
lady
[Music]
so cop showed her a photo of TC and
asked if he was the guy who bought the
petrol and the girl knew TC because she
was her sister babysat for TC okay it
feels like scones very small and she was
started with some TC because she knows
she said no but every week the cops are
show up and show her photo of a TC and
say it's the guy who bought two petrol
and she'd be like no I told you I know
that guy
now another Glasgow criminal William
love told the police he had evidence but
was in jail for armed robbery and was
offered release if he rolled on whoever
did the arson okay
love said just before the fire he
overheard TC and a guy named Joe steel
at a bar plotting to teach Fat Boy a
lesson but you hear that a lot of bars
yeah and there's a lot of fat boys Yeah
right TC was arrested for the Doyle
family murders okay the cops also
brought in his brother-in-law his nephew
and Agnes okay
and Joe Steele was also arrested Tam was
arrested and interrogated by the serious
crime squad and then just let go right
of course
I mean interrogated they sat in had
coffee with them well catch up at the
trial prosecutors focused on T C's
violent history evident evidence against
TC and Joe Steele seemed to just come
out of thin air
okay TC thumbprint was found in a car he
had never seen before
okay the police had a map they said they
found at T C's apartment
it had a large blue X on fatboys address
evidence I gotta say I think it's only
fair all those TC defenders best back
down now we found the incriminating
evidence oh well we find this thing that
said murder plan look at that he's got
the flames on the hands right there I'll
do it picture him right there his little
bauble saying I'll be the one to do this
he's written his name on his shirt on
the badge TC I don't believe we need any
more evidence especially any of the
forensic gained so well a journal entry
the day before I plan on burning fat
boys haste
well well well TC case closed
so four cops testified they all stated
that upon arresting T fee TC he said
quote I only wanted the van shot up the
fire at
Fat Boys was only meant to be a fright
nerd that went too far well again each
cop said the exact 24-hour word phrase
Wow
so far right unrehearsed coming out with
a gator with that that's right yeah TC a
man who was known as someone who died
before saying a single word to a cop
apparently confessed in front of four
cops okay he denied making the
confession what he's going back at his
word
I never they found the plan after the
map the ma'am and you're done
love testified he heard the exact same
words come out of TC at the bar quote I
only wanted the van shot up the fired
fat bus was only meant to be a fright
nerd that went too far are they saying
like zombie he said it he said it not
only in front of the cops but he also
say the exact same phrasing a bar wealth
if he was excited about the caper you
know how you get
it's like Christmas Eve for criminy
one criminal said he had never seen love
look so nervous or terrified as he
testified the police said they found a
jacket in the same car where t C's
thumbprint was discovered ah in the back
of the jacket murder plenty killer the
jacket was said to belong to t C's
brother-in-law hmm now during the trial
his lawyer asked the brother-in-law to
try on the jacket okay
the brother-in-law was small and when he
put the jacket on his sleeves were about
a foot too long and the court erupted in
laughter yeah yeah and the Johnnie
Cochran if the sleeves are too long the
verdict must be wrong oh that was good I
didn't expect that to go anywhere the
brother-in-law of TCC's nephew and Agnes
were all been acquitted of murder
charges cool okay but teasing Joe still
had the police maybe do like him like a
follow up where it's like all right guys
now let's talk about framing okay we had
a really good first crack at this we
really and again guys you did exactly
what I said and I can't fault you for
that now let's talk about what's too
on-the-nose when you overhear something
you guys got to invent new parts of it
new words things like that
sound verbatim okay felt like you guys
were reading it again I'm not mad at you
guys
I thought the co was great the code was
good again I think what was great about
the coat was the idea I know I didn't
know he had two tiny little dinosaurs a
little guy so that's what I then would
exactly be mine oh right they're mine oh
right there would exactly be that mine
oh right there would be next time fine
the guy would frame and get a look at it
might be a little guy yes might be a
bigger guy anyway the whole did I ask
you to try out something you might hear
the guy who sings that song crazy uh who
CeeLo yeah oh yeah sure
a little arm yeah yeah again I mean we
should have gotten his Jackie no no no
well yes but look we're not looking and
now would be the one we frame them with
no next time no next time they get a guy
with tiny sore arms jagged or just fine
it to go buy a dog coat okay go do
something like that there's there's
other ways to do this guy's all right
and the last thing would be the the map
very very obvious or obvious I know I
know a seamstress I think they're called
the yeah yeah we moved on sure yes what
the whole thing is they fit I'll get a
jacket from a kid sure these are all
things that would have been great these
are doing great a week ago right yes
this would have been great a week ago we
really synced up our words no longer in
a bad way that's what I'm saying a bad
way in a way that was very obvious was
good very obvious no good take the notes
these are the notes symposium so T
seeing Joe still had reliable alibis TC
insisted he was being framed
he said the map was planted in his
apartment and claimed when he had
brought I've been brought to the jail
the senior police officer said quote
this is where we do the fitting up I'm
gonna nail you to the wall
ah so call back so if TC and Joe were
innocent that would mean that almost
every cop on the case was corrupt should
imagine so Lord King prayed I'll come
down for this one
who was the trial judge I'm wealthy
could not believe the allegations of
police corruption he refused to accept
it was possible that many police
officers would be corrupt the word of a
criminal could not away the word of a
cop of course not
so TC and Joe Steele were found guilty
of murder in 1984 and given life
sentence Wow
in the 1980s the godfather of Glasgow
Arthur I remember from earlier yeah
he got into the heroin business nice you
mean he saved a lot of people okay
okay yeah no it's the kindness on
ice-cream jaw now he had his son Arthur
jr. run the operation good kid Arthur
Junior's nickname I didn't I obviously
couldn't use it fat boy really yeah okay
as a no ma sure he was just like well
you're all so far I think it's what they
call fat fat boy yes no you him me no
the fat one we're all fine he had Arthur
jr. run the operation are their senior
laundered the money and invested in
legitimate businesses at his peak he was
making a hundred thousand pounds a week
okay that's pretty good
yes he operated in the shadows Amazon
was impossible to catch his is neither
senior okay now Arthur jr. I'll be in
the shadows - dad did not share his
father's caution 30 Burnham he was
reckless okay he was a gun loving kid
who wanted the glamour of the gangster
life glamorous it's always it's always
the show buddy juniors always the guy
yeah and you wear sweat suits and gold
chains and he was known to shoot at
everything street signs trees even
random cars that passed him by on the
motorway like useless criminal behavior
for a criminal right that's very the
opposite of the caution his father
yeah is that like he's like dad got
caught again kidneys they caught me
again
so heroin is the biggest problem in
Glasgow so Laurel and Hardy asked
Tam's helped to catch some big dealers
okay in exchange for keeping tabs on
Arthur jr. they offered to give Tam the
confiscated heroin so he could resell it
what Lord featherbottom figure this
whatever that dude's name is got the
worst deal yeah what is the worst yeah
what am I get get out of jail free card
oh wait you're offering him the heroin
yeah
what about negotiating in the [ __ ]
middle yeah so Tam's like that's a great
deal I will totally take the head so Tam
sets up a meeting with Arthur jr. to pub
any proposals they start a partnership
he would give Arthur jr. heroin for free
now Arthur jr. didn't know where the
heroin came from but it was free and
this is a well-known criminal giving it
to him so he takes the deal great all
right I mean it doesn't seem like
there's any strings attached hey bear
one honey it's just a guy giving you
free heroin what what could be wrong
what's the pitch well give you a look
ahead of it well yeah so the heroin
turned out to be pure which was rare in
Scotland and it killed a lot of users
throughout the city because they were
used to bad junk that's right use a lot
well Arthur jr. was arrested okay
Arthur's senior suspected Tam had
something to do with the arrest sure and
but he went to taman are you offered him
twenty thousand pounds to get his son
out of prison probably the smarter move
and tam passed on the deal interesting
Arthur jr. got a 10-year sentence so so
Arthur seniors like but at the same time
Tam convinced Arthur the Arthur's junior
and senior that Paul Ferris who was
their enforcer had ratted out Arthur jr.
Tam's pretty he's pretty good he's
pretty good The Godfather at this point
is weak
and and now big part of the hewa markets
up for grabs with Arthur junior out of
the picture in 1988 Arthur's senior was
shot in the groin outside my goalies
[Music]
outside the family home which was in a
state called the Ponderosa Riley around
the time the steakhouse was around seems
like it's a know much one time we were
in the Las Vegas Airport and we stood by
at Ponderosa unbelievable cuts so after
you got shot he went to a private clinic
a privates clinic and told the police it
had been caused by a drill bit that
broke off yeah using teams I was
drilling in the wall and then it shot
through my cook a couple years later a
car ran over Arthur's senior on the curb
outside the Ponderosa again Arthur's
seniors survived will not give a
statement to police it was from a drill
on August 8 1991 Arthur jr. was on a
weekend leave from prison when he was
shot to death outside the Ponderosa bad
bad juju
our third senior was devastated evidence
pointed to Paul Ferris rift had
developed since Tama convinced them so
yes he added them out Arthur jr. tried
to kill him one point now so the police
again Tam the police arrested Ferris
for our third juniors murder and the
Godfather poured I don't know I don't
know how what he was doing but he poured
4.1 million pounds into the trial so to
get him convicted he's I don't know what
defining evidence or whatever hiring
investigators but whatever so he it
lasts 54 days and there's 300 witnesses
it at the time is the most expensive
trial and Scott Scotland history and the
Godfather broke the ultimate unspoken
rule amongst gangsters he testified
against another criminal in court mm-hmm
despite all that Ferris is acquitted Wow
Arthur's seniors criminal career is over
yeah so just days before Arthur juniors
funeral
Tamm killed two of Faris's partners by
shooting them in the head and with an
extra bullet shooting them in their
anuses oh come on let's what are we six
come on guys
clean it up everybody let's well because
this is this is why it's juvenile you
know we killed him first he didn't shoot
him in the ass and then they know he
shot him he goes head dad if fun see a
bit of a loss to be fair they're already
bullet wounds an idea officer Wow to
intimidate Arthur singer he dumped the
bodies along the route of the funeral
possession wait who did Tam dit yeah but
he think he was making it seem like
Ferris had done it Oh anybody so the
hearse passed the bodies the Godfather
was freaked out he spent the rest of his
life in hiding his son was dead his
daughter Margaret had died of a drug
overdose three years before he lived
secluded in fear and died a year later
on March 13th 1993 now Tam was the new
king okay throughout the 80s and 90s TC
put all his energy into filing an appeal
okay he protested his innocence by
refusing to have his hair cut that's the
way you know someone hasn't done since
right yeah yeah the hairiest did the
least you really showed them yeah he
lost his first appeal in 1989 but he
organized the inmates and they took over
the jail well that's how we do it okay
self start they could have left the
prison but TC stayed and demanded
justice interesting move the prison
guards didn't respond well he was beaten
so badly by the guards that he was
briefly pronounced dead probably should
have left that's
like that's a legit beating like yeah
that you're it's a quality bid oh sorry
Oh little bit Emery's this got the
attention of inmates all over Scotland
many believed TC was innocent according
to journalist reg McKay quote jails
erect men sat on rooftops for days
buildings torched screws were taken
hostage even nobody moved we've got the
screws is that what you said yeah the
screws screws are no oh that's what they
call guards in prison oh no they screw
oh you're so innocent I am not from here
even down in the dark dungeons of the
digger I know the diggers oh smart now I
a so weak half blind men created hell
banners were strung from the jail walls
free the Glasgow to the riots were for
the innocent the unjust were fighting
for justice nice so though all the
prison system was pretty cool yeah I
like solidarity it's a union well and
that I mean good lord
we could use that in 1992 two
journalists researching a book about the
s chemours
found that William love had admitted he
lied in court after that Joe Steele
escaped several times and staged large
demonstrations he went superglued and
changed himself to the gates of
Buckingham Palace what how much time do
you need to superglue years there's
guards everywhere oh there is what the
[ __ ] where to go I don't know I was
there for it's fleeting
yeah right there well how so he he
literally literally glued it's he's
handcuffed and he glued himself his
hands are glued I say I think he's
escaping and doing this or he's getting
out that's TC who did no this is the
other guy Joe steamed okay
them right right okay that's who hates
TC right so they're connected because of
this thing but he he like never had
anything to do with it but he's like TC
was all involved in the [ __ ] ice
cream war [ __ ]
I never was I just got sucked up in it
right so he's also wearing a shirt of
Jesus on the kritis the [ __ ] best
no he's yeah it's a painting within a
painting TC was sent to solitary
confinement and started waging hunger
strikes he neared death several times
when he was asked who killed the Doyles
TC would reply quote how the [ __ ] should
I know I wasn't there
fair fair one ex-criminal began to
organize campaigns for the Glasgow two
and openly blamed Tam for the Doyle
murders he opened an office in an ex
factory to run the campaign but Tam
bought the building and evicted him okay
alright Tam keep trying so the guy went
and confronted Tam at a bar and shouted
at him and berated Tam in front of all
of his associates Jesus dude and Glasgow
public embarrassing someone like this
was called a shrieking sure a week later
he was lured to a pub surrounded by
armed men and shot dead yeah I mean I
appreciate the passion yeah but it's not
come on if you wanted like I mean so the
guy the guy who got away with burning a
house down yes yeah that's not the guy
you want to confront at a bar yeah right
yeah exactly I mean yeah fight him but
you know yo please do not investigate
the murder it's just a bar yeah I mean
guy getting a shot no well that looks
pretty open-and-shut to me suicide but
pressure led TC and steel so now there's
a lot of people now who are like these
guys didn't do it right politicians
getting involved and was like this is
not so pressure leads to TC and Steel
being released on bail in late 1996
pending a second appeal okay one day
after being let out TC was getting a
prescription for his daughter at a
pharmacy when one of Tam's henchmen
stabbed him multiple times
Christ but TC overpowered the pennmen
the henchmen then another man that
jumped out of a car and attacked TC with
a 7-iron which he went got out of the
trunk he wasn't holding it he had golf
with the trunk grab one witnesses said
the guy with the golf club was Tam ok
cops did nothing Wow
TC survived then the appeal was so out
in the open like yeah it turns out when
there's corruption just anything goes
yeah but even then I mean I know it's
pretty bility to be able to go out with
a7 I mean a Jack Nicklaus some guy or
Jack Nicklaus you Jack Nicholson yeah
that one all of them the appeal was
rejected loves lies redeemed not to have
an effect on the outcome of the original
trial so they were like there was so
much evidence that loves love's
snitching didn't matter TC and Steele
will return to prison in 1998 that year
Tam was arrested for drug smuggling
interesting which i think is outside the
local okay here's why so he was taking
underprivileged kids from housing
schemes on minibus holidays to Morocco
or Spain I'm sure the goodness of his
heart the buses had drugs stored
directly below the kids seats police
found out and they confiscated 220
pounds of weed and 12 kids and 12 kids
Tam was charged okay but walked away
with no explanation interesting and his
brother-in-law got 10 years Jesus Christ
so it is just him I mean he's just still
just after all these years TC and
steelwill recent released again on
appeal after a new commission was formed
to deal with all the [ __ ]
convictions in scotland so they
literally form a commission to undo the
town not just how many people have
became convicted by [ __ ] crimes so
those guys the the Commission good for
them though yeah the Commission gets him
out so that so they they have any trial
an expert testifies that
the four police officers could not
possibly make four identical statements
it was nearly impossible he did a study
and he went and he had all these people
he would tell the people the sentence
and then he went all these people try to
repeat the confession but a vast
majority could not he was clear the cops
had memorized the statement prior to the
trial so TC and Steele were freed
permanently in 2004 Wow they had spent
18 years in jail the original trial
judge Lord King Craig said he still
quote could not accept there was
conspiracy among the police
hey King Craig go away how could the
police were there police all they do is
good they are the police yes all police
do is good right there's no way more
than one police could get together and
be bad ever Lord it's never happened in
the police lord of all the police's and
all the police towns there's never been
a bunch of police's that are bad like
that for in his little wig please call
me bad they're all good
the original trial judge said that and
the original trials transcript Lord King
King Craig had told the jury that quote
to believe Campbell and Steele's
assertions was to accept that not one or
two or four about a large number of
detectives have deliberately come here
to perjure themselves yes to build a
book false case against an accused
person yes it was to saddle the accused
wrongly with the crimes of murder and
attempted murder and a murder of a
horrendous nature there's no way yeah Oh
God have you heard of the FBI so he he
had apparently never listened to police
in a courtroom before TC openly said Tam
was the real Doyle family murder but Tam
would never be suspected of TC and
Steele were in jail so Tam was obviously
doing everything could to get them in
jail the whole time
TC tried to have the Doyle family
mergers investigation reopened but it
was seen as a personal vendetta against
him and so they wouldn't but it's also
not a personal vendetta like it's both
it's both yeah
he had also over this time he kept
trying to get TC killed like he was
trying to yes clearly yeah I mean it
gets very personal yeah several
politicians have backed an inquiry into
the investigation the ice cream Moore's
was one of those high-profile cases in
Scottish legal history it shook the
public and demand and damaged its faith
and local police it is believed by some
many are in jail in Scotland because of
police lies after TC and Steele were
released
Tam's loyal henchmen were picked off one
by one two close associates were
murdered the death of a Billy McPhee
scared Tam the most Billy was at a bar
in Bali Stein watching a game when an
unidentified man in a gray hoodie and
jeans walked in and repeatedly stabbed
him but that just sounds like being in a
pub in Scotland well potentially but I
mean 8:00 he died in 19 minutes he died
so Tama just survived an assassination
attempt that month and he had also been
shot in the head recently so Tam went
into hiding in 2003 splitting his time
between safe houses all over Ireland
Scotland in Spain Arthur's seniors other
son Billy was in and out of prison he
got 18 months in the late 90s for
possessing a harpoon gun well if you're
gonna go if you're gonna go go big go
big
everything to do this story because it
is it's about growing up in it and
trying to be bigger than your father and
trying to show people that you are your
own thing you don't even like if someone
started carrying like a katana sword
it'd be like alright well this guy's
he's a sword guy but you know you want
to be the guy who's with like what is it
a rocket launcher no that's just them
that's a land harpoon he's carrying that
man is straight up carrying whale
killing equipment on his shoulder right
now
where's Fat Boy Billy also died in 2017
due to drugs so out of all of Arthur's
kids only one still alive okay tam spent
his final years in a heavily fortified
home in Glasgow
he watched reruns of Star Trek all day
no I liked him and passed away after a
heart attack on July 30 2007 on June 26
2009 teen TC died at the age of 66 Joe
Steele who's now 57 has turned his back
on crime and has been sober for six
years to this day there still has not
been an inquiry into the Glasgow police
corruption not a single officer has been
investigated discipline or jailed and
the Doyle family murders remain unsolved
Wow Wow even though we all know who did
it yeah Fat Boy that's right yeah it
killed his own yeah hmm yeah boy that's
crazy isn't it that is crazy how how is
that not gonna oh my god it's one of the
best movies of all time it's Gangs of
New York in Scotland with ice cream
truck but better it's really [ __ ] but
I am wow that's crazy man that's crazy
because it's so real ways look at
Scotland as a place that really has its
[ __ ] together and it for the most part
it does I remember so I used to watch a
lot of guy what's the the prison show on
MSNBC that was onyl and locked up yeah i
swatched a lot of lockup and they
started international lockup and they
and they start going to Scott and it was
like it's the number one per capita for
stabbings like it was just like I think
it's a lot better now but I think for a
while Scotland just had a [ __ ]
because remember Martha thatch Margret
Thatcher went through and [ __ ]
destroyed the country and then then then
drugs go up in crime yeah crime goes up
so well that's the I mean and every time
you I mean it's just like you can paint
by numbers how you get drug infestation
into cities no it's pretty simple yeah
you know pull out the safety net take
away the job yeah and right away I mean
what's gonna go you know and and then
yeah and then make drugs available yeah
I mean mm-hmm
we should get an ice cream van
you and me I mean it's just so weird
because now with like the food like I'm
just picturing foot like if food trucks
were just like like somebody's food
trucks kill each other I mean he's good
with what meal yeah the grilled cheese
van and that lobster tacos they killed
each other's families
what yeah be great yeah be great that's
what I'm after I'm all for it that's
great
all right all right well gobble-gobble
everybody when we signed the trial
[Music]